Now that you know how to test your
game it's time to think about
how you can get your game noticed.
>> App stores house hundreds
of thousands of apps
with more being added each day.
So how can your game stand out?
>> The first thing that potential
players notice is what your game looks
like, based on the icon and
screenshots in the app store.
>> And it's also important to
have a descriptive name, so
people have an idea of what your game
is about as soon as they see it.
>> This section will be all about how
to optimize your app store presence
by designing everything from your
game icon to its description.
>> Then you'll be ready
to submit your app.